Here's the transition
function that I used.
I'll write it out piece by piece.
First, we need to move to
the end of the input string.
So we have q0 transition
to itself on 0n1 and
only move into state q1 when
it encounters a blank symbol.
Since we rewound to the left after
reading the first blank symbol,
the head now reads the last
symbol of the string.
We overwrite this symbol with a blank,
but we remember what the symbol was by
going into state q2 if it was a 0,
and then to state q3 if it was a 1.
In both cases, we move to the right.
The next symbol will
necessarily be a blank and
we want to replace it with a 0 or
a 1 as appropriate.
We move the head to the left, and
then left again to return to the last
symbol of the unshifted string.
Eventually, the whole string
will have been shifted, and
this move will try to move past
the beginning of the tape.
In this case,
the head stays where it is, and
so we read the blank symbol again.
We use this as a signal to
indicate the machine should halt.
So we write the dollar sign and
do so in the accepting state.